et votre mari dit de vous on ne la force
que jamais à dire c'est qu'elle ne veut
pas dire et pas davantage à faire ce
qu'elle n'avait pas fait alors moi je
vais quand même vous demander quelque
chose pour conclure je ne vous ai je
voulais toujours connu avec un chignon
est ce que si je vous demandais
maintenant étonné qu'on est dans cette
phase de séduction de charme terrasse
est vrai qu'une femme à cheveux longs
est toujours différent d'une fois
machine si je vous demandais de dfa
votre chinois je l'avais bien sûr alors
je vous de grand voile a tout de suite
tout de suite si vous voulez je n'ai pas
toujours eu les cheveux longs et je
regrette beaucoup d'avoir les cheveux
longs j'ai les cheveux longs depuis que
finisse enfin j'ai commencé à laisser
pousser à ce moment là parce que c'était
beaucoup beaucoup plus facile de se
recoiffer quand on est en voyage tout le
temps et que il faut être pratiquement
présentable sinon il faut pouvoir aller
chez le coiffeur tous les jours qui
n'est pas parce qu'il n'est pas facile
c'est la première le régime des gammes
est arrivé une fois ou deux mais je me
souviens une fois comme ça aux états
unis où j'étais d'ailleurs en
déplacement officiel et je vous l'avais
bien faire un chignon chez le coiffeur
pour être coiffé pendant le voyage et et
je n'ai pas pu trouver le coiffeur qui
s'achevèrent et sign on n'a pas pu m'a
dit je ne peux pas alors bon ben ça avec
nous à faire c'était c'était accepter
d'avoir d'avoir les cheveux longs
[Musique]